voilà le clavier de oneplus alors c'est
vrai qu'on attend pas oneplus dans
l'univers du gaming dans l'univers de la
bureautique avec un clavier ça c'est
vraiment un clavier de gaming et surtout
c'est un clavier mécanique alors il a
été annoncé il y a quelques temps il y a
un côté qui est vraiment rétro j'ai
l'impression de retrouver un vieux
clavier dans le vieil ordi et pour
autant on reste dans un truc très très
actuel on trouve la touche Escape qui
est la touche oneplus donc si on veut
s'échapper on appuie sur oneplus et puis
on a cette espèce de molette qui nous
permettra probablement pour des usages
un petit peu créatifs ou pour lui gaming
j'en sais rien du tout en plus viens
tester d'autres choses va dans d'autres
univers continue à développer son
écosystème c'était quand même la marque
qui sortait un produit par an depuis
deux produits par an qui a ensuite
ouvert une gamme plus en milieu de gamme
la gamme d'or à voir jusqu'où ils vont
aller dites-moi ce que vous en pensez de
ce clavier mécanique de oneplus est-ce
qu'un réel intérêt pour vous est-ce que
c'est juste un effet d'annonce et tant
pis que oneplus a annoncé que cette
année en 2023 ils allaient sortir leur
premier smartphone qui se plaît le truc
qui est vraiment extrêmement intéressant
alors est-ce que ce sera un peu comme un
smartphone de oppo en un peu moins
spécqué on va dire allez savoir en tout
cas on en parlera très bien tôt donc
bien évidemment connectez-vous
abonnez-vous et dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez surtout dans les commentaires